my goal in this video and the next few
is to start
giving a sense of the scale of really
just the earth and the solar system and
as we see as we start getting into like
the galaxy in the universe it just
becomes almost impossible to imagine but
we'll at least give our best shot so i
think most of us watching this video
know that this right here is earth
this right here is earth and just to get
a sense of scale here i think probably
probably the largest distance that we
can somehow relate to is about 100 miles
you can get into a car for an hour hour
and a half and go about 100 miles and on
the earth that would be about this far
it would be a spec that would look
something like that that is a hundred
miles and also to get us a bit of scale
let's think about a speed that at least
we can kind of comprehend and that would
be maybe the speed of a so let's think
of the speed
speed of a bullet
speed of a bullet maybe we can't
comprehend it but i'll say this is the
fastest thing that we can maybe kind of
comprehend it goes about and there are
different types of bullets depending on
the type of gun and all of that about
280 meters per second which is about one
thousand
one thousand kilometers
one thousand kilometers per hour and
this is also roughly this is also
roughly the speed
the speed of a jet
of
a jet
so just to give a sense of scale here
the earth's circumference
the earth's circumference so if you were
to go around the planet
the earth's circumference just like that
is about 40 000 kilometers it is 40 000
kilometers 40 000
kilometers so if you were to travel at
the speed of a bullet speed of a bullet
or the speed of a jetliner
at a thousand kilometers an hour it
would take you 40 hours to
circumnavigate the earth 40 hours to go
around the earth so it would take you 40
hours
40 hours to go around the earth and i
think these none of this information is
too surprising you might have taken a 12
or 15 hour flights that get you not all
the way around the earth but get you
pretty far san francisco to australia or
something like that so right now these
aren't at scales that are are too crazy
although you know even for me even the
earth itself is a pretty mind-blowingly
large object now with that out of the
way let's think about the sun because
the sun starts to approach something far
huger so this obviously here is the sun
and i think most people appreciate that
the sun is larger that it's much larger
than the earth and that it's pretty far
away from the earth but i don't think
most people including myself fully
appreciate how large the sun is or how
far it is away from the earth so just to
give you a sense the earth the sun has
the sun has is 109
times the circumference
times the circumference
of the earth
times the circumference of the earth so
if we do that same thought exercise
there
if we said okay if i'm traveling at the
speed of a bullet or the speed of a
jetliner it would take me 40 hours to go
around the earth well how long would it
take to go around the sun
so if you were to get on a if you were
to get on a jet plane and try to go
around the sun or if you were to somehow
ride a bullet and try to go around the
sun go do a complete circumnavigation of
the sun it's going to take you 109 times
as long as it would have taken you to do
the earth so it would be 100
times i could do 109 but just for
approximate it's roughly 100 times the
circumference of the earth so 109 times
40 is equal to 4
4 000
4 000 hours and just to get a sense of
what 4 000 is actually since i have the
calculator out let's do the exact
calculation it's 109 times the
circumference 109 times the
circumference of the earth
times 40 hours
that's what it would take to do the
circumference of the earth so it's 4
360 hours to circumnavigate the sun
going at the speed of a bullet or a
jetliner and so that is
24 hours of the day that is 181 days it
would take you roughly half a year it
would take half a year to go around the
sun at the speed of a jetliner let me
write this down half a year
half
a
year
the sun is huge the sun is huge
now that by itself may or may not be
spread actually let me give you a sense
of scale here because i have this other
diagram of a sun
this other diagram of a sun and we'll
talk more about the rest of the solar
system in the next video but over here
at this scale at the sun the sun at
least on my screen if i were to complete
it would probably about be about 20
inches in diameter the earth is just
this little thing over here small
smaller than a raindrop it's just a
small
little thing
over here if i were to draw it on this
scale where the sun is even smaller the
earth would be about
that
the earth would be right about that big
now what isn't obvious because we've all
done our science projects in third and
fourth grade or we always see these
diagrams of the solar system that look
something like this is that these
planets are way further away even though
these are this is these are
depicted to scale they're way further
away from the sun than this makes it
look so the sun
so sorry the earth is a hundred and
fifty million kilometers from the sun
so the earth
earth is
so this this if this is if this is the
sun right here if this was the sun right
here you wouldn't even at this scale you
wouldn't even be able to see the earth
you wouldn't be able to see the earth it
wouldn't even be a pixel but it would be
150
it would be 150 million
150
million
150 million kilometers
from the earth and this distance right
here is called an astronomical unit
we'll be using that term in the next few
videos just because it's an easier way
to think about distance
sometimes abbreviated a you astronomical
unit
astronomical
astronomical unit and just to give a
sense of how far this it is a light
which is something that we think is
almost infinitely fast you know
something that looks instantaneous that
takes eight minutes to travel from the
sun to the earth if the sun were to
disappear it would take eight minutes
for that light for us to know that it
disappeared
on earth or another way just to put it
in in the sense of of this jet airplane
let's get the calculator back out
so we have a hundred we're talking about
150
that's a thousand million that's 150
million kilometers so if we're going at
a thousand kilometers an hour
so if we go to thousand kilometers hour
would take us 150 000 hours at the speed
of a bullet or at the speed of a jet
plane to get to the sun and just to get
put that in perspective
that if we want it in days there's 24
24 hours per day
so this would be
6250 days or if we divide by 365 roughly
17 years if you were to shoot a bullet
straight at the sun it would take 17
years to get there if it could maintain
its velocity somehow so this would take
a bullet or a jet plane 17 years to get
to the sun
17
17 years or another way to visualize it
this sun right over here it looks on my
screen it has about a five or six inch
diameter
if i were to actually do it as scale
this little dot right here this little
dot which is the earth this speck
this spec if i actually wanted to draw
this distance at scale i would have to
put this speck about 50 feet away from
the sun 50 or 60 feet away from the sun
if you were to look at the solar system
and obviously there's other things in
the solar system we'll talk more about
them in the next video you wouldn't even
notice a speck this is a little dust
thing flying around this sun and we as
we go further and further out of this
solar system you can see even this
distance starts to become ridiculously
small or another way to think about it
if you if the sun was about this size if
the sun was about this size then this
speck
then the earth at this scale would be
about 200 feet away from it so you could
imagine if you had a football field if
you had a football field
so let me draw a football field
these are the end zones one end zone
another end zone and you just stick
something maybe the size of a medicine
soap ball a little bit bigger than a
basketball at one end zone this little
speck would be
about 60 yards away or about roughly 60
meters away so it's a little speck you
wouldn't even notice it on the scale of
a football field something this size
anyway i'm going to leave you there
hopefully that gives you just
starts to blow your mind when you think
about just just the scale of the sun the
earth and how far the earth is away from
the sun and then we're going to see even
those distances even those scales are
super small when you start thinking
about
the rest of the solar system and
especially when we start going beyond
the solar system